good morning
i'd like to uh call this special meeting
of the fiscal committee to order
uh our purpose today is to
go through the claims process that the
attorney general has
put together
and i would uh
like him to walk us through the entire
process
write your questions or comments or
thoughts
and um
when uh he's finished with his
presentation
then
we will ask our questions and
go from there
so
general famela if you would please
uh
well thank you madam chair and good
morning to you and the members of the
committee
for the record john farmela attorney
general and i am joined once again by
senior assistant attorney general jen
ramsey who many of you now know very
well especially if you were involved in
the legislative process so jen is here
with me because she has
put a lot of work herself into the
preparation of this claims process and
guidelines package so she'll be here to
help answer questions and
and take feedback from the committee
so i just i want to start by
giving just a little bit of an overview
and some background on how we got here
today
um as you know
this past session the legislature
enacted house bill 1677 which
established the ydc settlement fund
and as part of that bill this office was
directed to develop a a claims process
and guidelines
uh which includes claim forms uh process
and rules for how this
this um this process would work and
guidelines for how we would value claims
and payout claims
so that is what we have done we
submitted that
to the lba who's given it to you
and the fiscal committee
is
has the role under this bill of either
approving the process or
objecting or giving not approving the
process and giving us some feedback on
concerns that then we would we would
take into account and and come back with
revisions to address
so that that is why we are here today
the fund that is set up by ht hb 1677 as
we've talked about since january and the
process that this bill sets up
it is intended to provide an alternative
option
for victims who may have suffered sexual
or physical abuse while residents at ydc
or or
or a facility that was under another
name
that that's a similar facility
we felt that it was important to set up
a process like this because as we've
talked about now a lot
the traditional litigation process can
be very difficult for anyone
but it can be especially difficult for
those who may have been victims of
sexual abuse or physical abuse
especially when that abuse occurred
while the victim was a child
so our goal when we brought this forward
to the legislature and as we work
through the legislative process
was to establish this as an alternative
to traditional litigation
as i've stated before and as you all
know there's another part of our office
that continues to
inve
conduct a criminal investigation into
the allegations of abuse at ydc
um to date we've indicted 11 former
state employees
for
the alligator for for um offenses
related to the allegations brought
forward by 22 victims so since the end
of the legislative session we have now
brought criminal charges for two
additional
victims allegations and we we
continue to investigate we expect that
that investigation will continue for
some time probably years
most of those trials have now been
scheduled the first trial is scheduled
for january of 2023 in the criminal
cases uh scheduled for january of 2023
they run through may of 2024 there are a
couple of cases which have yet to be
scheduled for trial but we expect those
to be scheduled for trial soon so
we will have a lot of criminal trials in
these cases running through 2023 and
2024.
as required by the the statute we have
made what i believe are absolutely good
faith efforts to negotiate this package
with claimants counsel
we started by circulating first drafts
back in june
we we posted those drafts on our website
we sent these drafts to all claimants
council that we were aware of
we sent notices out to the entire bar
to make sure that that every attorney in
the state was aware that this was
happening so that we could make sure
that that we were notifying anyone who
could potentially have a a client that
might come through this process that
they had the opportunity to engage with
our office in the development
of this package
um part of the benefit of posting the
the drafts on the website
is that that also
get
that also gave the ability for the
public to see where we were going with
this so we wanted to be very transparent
we wanted everyone to see how this was
evolving in real time up to
our final draft that we have submitted
to you
today
for the most part i will say claimants
council have chosen not to engage in the
process
that that's their decision it's their
right to do so i will say it's somewhat
disappointing from my perspective that
we haven't gotten more engagement from
claimants counsel but
we have made
every effort to to facilitate that
engagement we've offered in-person
meetings
we've offered to sit down with anyone
who wanted to talk about this process so
so i think that we have really made
some extensive efforts on that front
the statute or the bill that was passed
also directed our office to consult with
our victim witness advocates and we have
done that
a great deal
of the difference between the first
drafts and the drafts that
you see before you today is due to the
input from our victim witness advocates
they've given us great feedback they've
given us great ideas on how to simplify
this process as much as we can
and i just want to take the opportunity
to publicly acknowledge and thank them
for their efforts and their input
they have a different role in our office
so their role is has always been and and
is today
focused on assisting and supporting
victims so so they gave us great
feedback
they understand that this is a this
process is a balance between
making this as simple and easy for
victims as it can be while also
providing for appropriate
factual review and verification so i
think they understand that balance and
they understand that um that we're
trying to walk that line and we have a
real needle to threat
i know that this package as it appears
before you today may seem somewhat
daunting especially as we try to view
this package from the perspective of an
average person
or an unrepresented victim who may come
through this process
so i just want to i want to note a
couple things on that front and i'm sure
we're gonna have
a fair amount of conversation about that
today
first i think it's important to note
that
much of this material is not material
that that a victim or a claimant would
need to be going through themselves
part of the package you have are the
claims process and the guidelines
those serve as sort of the governing
rules behind this process which
really will be governing the conduct of
the administrator the conduct of the
attorney general designee the conduct of
claimants counsel and governing how the
claims are valued
a victim or a claimant is not going to
be required to sift through all of that
so that's
that's one important thing to note
a second important thing to note is that
the vast majority of claimants or
potential claimants that we are aware of
are represented by council and when i
say vast majority i mean you know
percentages in the high 90s we're i'm
not sure we're aware of of anyone beyond
one or two individuals who we
as of now
we know of who would come through this
process without an attorney so i just
think that's important to be aware of we
absolutely cannot assume that anyone
that anyone and everyone who would come
through this process will have a lawyer
but i think we can be pretty confident
that the vast majority
of those who come through this process
will
so
from my perspective that that has played
a role in our thinking in the balance
between trying to keep this simple
streamlined and digestible while also
ensuring that we would collect enough
information to evaluate a claim
something else to keep in mind is that
an unrepresented victim who comes
through this process is going to
experience this process in a different
way than than we're experiencing
experiencing it here today as we
go through all of these documents
for the purpose of this committee
evaluating whether to approve the
documents
i think if an unrepresented victim comes
to this process they'll come to it by
seeing either an ad or a notice that
goes out
they'll hear about it by word of mouth
they'll see it online they'll see the
contact information for the
administrator's office and they
if they're not reaching out to a lawyer
to help take them through the process
they'll be reaching out to the
administrator's office
and we expect that that office will be
set up in such a way that they will
give victims not they won't just drop up
the package on a victim or a claimant
and say here it is you know
fill it out and send it in and
and we'll we'll get back to you they
will not experience this process in a
way that you experience other processes
where
you fill something out and if you leave
one thing blank it just gets kicked back
to you
with uh you know
not complete please complete right
they'll get simple straightforward
responses from the administrator's
office and
we intend and we expect
and i think it's reflected in these
documents that the administrator's
office will provide assistance to
claimants in filling out this packet the
administrator's office will
not kick back a a claim form because
it's incomplete they will accept the
form
and they will reach out to the claimant
to offer and provide assistance in
getting
enough information into that claim form
so that the claim can be evaluated
i think this is really important because
as i've talked
with especially with our victim witness
advocates we know that
any individual victim could have or
there is a wide variety of of ways in
which any potential victim might
interact with a process like this you
can have
you have a spectrum that runs anywhere
from someone who is barely able to get
get a few sentences down on paper to
someone who
is ready to fill out the entire form and
you have to be ready to
[Music]
to
assist and work with a wide range of
victims on that front
but we can't we also can't assume
anything about individual victims we we
can't assume that any one victim may not
be able to fill this out we can't assume
that any one victim may be able to fill
it out so
this is this is a challenge for us and
one that we are aware of and we've
worked very hard to try to to try to
accommodate that we will have a wide
range of individuals who might come
through this process
we also expect and we've had
conversations with the administrative
office of the courts on this front who
will be responsible for helping set up
the infrastructure for the
administrator's office
we expect that this that the claim form
in the worksheet will be made available
through a website format so that a
claimant or victim would have the option
of filling this out
on a website
the advantage of that which you'll see
as we walk through the documents is that
the claim form for instance that you
have before you is
especially long because it is intended
to lay out
all of the potential
information you might have to fill out
for any situation that you might that
that you might be under as a victim
so
you'll notice in the form it'll say
things like if you filled out this part
you don't have to fill out that part if
you filled out that part you don't have
to fill out this part
if you are claiming this then you don't
have to fill out that
the paper form has to lay all of that
out
but the webs the web option
will be much simpler for a claimant for
a victim because it will automatically
direct them
through depending on what they've put
into the to the fields so i think having
that option available will be
will be helpful and will help to
streamline this process even more
for a claimant who who is unrepresented
and maybe is accessing this through the
website
again we obviously have to have paper
forms because we can't assume that any
claimant would have access would have
internet access or access to a computer
but but having that option available i
think will be helpful
the last piece i just want to note is
that
you'll notice in our in our request for
approval that whether this is approved
today or or down the line we've we've
requested approval to make
non-substantive changes going forward
that would just enhance readability
um
you know
enhance readability and make make this
process easier to follow so an example
of that would be
putting in more places on the form this
is where you call for assistance or
putting moving to the front
bold lettering that says this is where
you go for assistance and just making
clear where people need to go to access
assistance with with completing this
process if they need it
so because of all of that i i would
i would just say that i think what's
important for today and what what is
really the meat
of
of what this committee needs to be
thinking about
is the substance of the documents so how
are the claims going to be handled
how are they going to be valued
um
what processes are being put in place to
ensure that claims are being valued
fairly and that similar situated
claimants
would get similar
values for their claims out of this
process
i think that's all consistent with our
goal of providing an alternative
option to traditional litigation that is
easier and more victim
friendly and trauma informed than
traditional litigation
while recognizing that
there will still be some level of
process that that has to come along with
this because we all we do have an
obligation i think at the end of the day
to ensure that we're we're
conducting enough
enough of a review to verify facts and
verify the information we're getting
so that we can be sure we're paying out
claims fairly i think that's not that
doesn't come just from an obligation to
the taxpayer not to pay out money
inappropriately it comes from an
obligation to be fair we want
to do everything we can
to
to ensure that
people who may have experienced
one form of abuse or another
are receiving the same compensation as
those who who experience similar abuse
and that we don't have disparities
so
with that i will
i'll turn to the documents specifically
but just say one more thing about what
what how we have sort of internalized
what we think is the intent of hb6
1677 and how that's reflected in these
documents
we've always viewed the intent of hp
1677 again as as providing an
alternative to traditional litigation
and we view the directive in this
legislation
to us
as one that asks us to balance again
the obligation to provide
compensation to victims through an
accessible process that balances that
obligation with the obligation that we
have to the taxpayers and the people of
the state to make sure this is fair and
that this
uh that we pay out money appropriately
so that overall is sort of the exercise
that we're going here it's going for
here it's a little bit of a needle to
thread and
as we've said before and i think we all
recognize this is this is unprecedented
i think that it is great that the state
is doing this but we have never done
anything like this before and to our
knowledge no state has ever done
anything like this before so we are
treading
new ground i think we're um i think
we're treading new ground in a good way
but because of that you know i think
this process warrants warrants the care
and and due diligence and work that has
been set up in hp 1677
sorry turned off my microphone
with that i will turn to the documents
specifically
the package you have is about 89 pages
but it really breaks down into three
parts
the first part is the claims process
this part
just high level it tracks the statute
for the most part but it also fills in
details and gaps that the statute may
not have filled in
so this is the piece of the of the
package that provides for the procedures
that are to be followed by the claimant
the administrator and the ag designee as
the claim moves through the process
this process is uh or this document is
designed to be posted publicly
we expect that there might be updates
and additions from time to time
depending on how this goes the hb 16
1677 does provide that the administrator
consulting with claimants council and
the ag could come back to fiscal to
propose revisions to the process so we
would expect that that that may happen
once the administrator is appointed and
sort of takes control of this
the second piece and i will go through
these in more detail but i'm just
summarizing each piece the second piece
that you have
which really starts on page 21 are the
guidelines
the guidelines are the first appendix to
the claims process and the guidelines
deal specifically
with how to value claims so the claims
process deals with procedure
the guidelines deal with how to value
the claims
so as the statute requires the
guidelines group claims into categories
by type
so type of abuse
and they also take into account
aggravating factors and mitigating
factors
this is the document this is the the
piece of this package that assigns the
dollar amounts
there's some discretion for the
administrator when it comes to valuation
because at the end of the day the
administrator
is going to retain a certain amount of
discretion as to how to apply mitigating
factors
but for the most part we've tried to
keep the guidelines fairly formulaic
because at the end of the day
the bill that was passed
directs that the guidelines the goal of
the guidelines is to ensure the fair and
uniform valuation of claims
so that the claims of similarly situated
claimants are valued similarly
so basically that's just a way of saying
the goal of the guidelines is to ensure
fairness and the best way to do that or
i should say
the way we do that when you have
potentially hundreds of claimants coming
through a process is to have a process
that frankly is somewhat formulaic
because only by having
a formula be the base of evaluation
process can you ensure fairness if you
leave too much discretion to the
administrator you risk having
inconsistencies in how claims are valued
and then the last
piece of this that you have is the
claims packet
this
consists of a number of items and this
is what a claimant or a victim will
really be going through and filling out
with either assistance from their
attorney or assistance from staff uh the
administrator's staff
so that was just an overview of the
three documents i will now
proceed into going into some greater
detail
for each one
i'm going to keep this somewhat high
level only because there is a lot here
and i
i don't want to you know spend two hours
going through the details of everything
here but but i'll keep it high level and
then we will be prepared to take any
questions you may have
as a first just housekeeping item you'll
notice that
at the top left
of this package
are page numbers and these are meant to
be sort of page numbers for the whole
package so when i refer to a page number
i'm going to be referring
to what's in the top hand corner where
it says jfc page 1 2 3 etc
so again the claims process which is
found on pages 1 through 20 of your
packet referencing the top left corner
again this
this
is sort of the rules of the road
procedure-wise
so this this process governs how the
administrator the aeg designee the
claimant claimants counsel are to
proceed
on a procedural basis
this process basically has three
components
it describes
how you go about submitting and
completing a claim
so filling out the form
interact attaching necessary documents
interacting with the administrator
and so on
it also
um
deals with the ag designee's review and
position that's the second component of
the claims process so once a form
once a claim is submitted once a claim
is complete or i should say complete
enough
the aeg designee has a chance to review
it and give a position
and then this process outlines
and it a resolution proceeding before
the administrator
if we get that far
so again to summarize phase one
deals with how a claimant pulls together
what they need
to submit a claim deals with how a
claimant fills out the claim form we
provided a claim form for this which
we'll go through when we get to the
claims packet and a list of items that
need to be submitted
again if something is submitted that's
incomplete that's fine
we envision that there could be
claimants who are not represented by
counsel who may submit a form that only
has a couple pieces of information on it
as long as their name and contact
information is on the form we would
envision that if that happens there
the form will not or the claim form will
not be rejected it will be accepted and
there will be outreach to that claimant
to assist them
with how to complete the form at least
complete it to enough of a point that we
can do an evaluation of the claim
as part of that
you know there are details that remain
to be worked out with the administrator
once the administrator is appointed but
we would envision that
the administrator would have staff but
also that the administrator may make
contract with
with an organization that provides that
could provide assistance um using using
trained advocates we recognize that that
a
secretary while well
or an executive assistant while
qualified to do many tasks may not be
um perfectly positioned to assist a
victim of sexual abuse with filling out
a claim form so we we envision that the
administrator
will will
contract with an appropriate
organization to provide that type of
assistance if needed
once a claim
is submitted
the process provides that it moves to
the aeg designees review so a claim is
submitted and then the
ag designee who will be somebody in our
office
will conduct an initial review of the
claim
as part of that review they'll review
the information that's submitted on the
claim form
they will
review any documents that our office
might have or have access to review
records
to make a determination
as to what what the our office's
position would be on a claim we
envisioned that it may very well be that
that we'll have claims where we review
it we think there's enough information
there we think what's there is credible
and we would take the position that the
claim should be paid out in full
depending um whatever the amount was
that was submitted
there also could be a situation where we
review a claim and we
we think that more information is needed
and we would request
the administrator to appoint an
investigator to investigate the claim
so that could be part of that step
that
our office reviews the claim and
requests an investigation
it's then up to the administrator to
either refer the claim to investigation
or not
so that decision will not be made by our
office that decision as to whether to
refer the claim for an investigation
will be made by the administrator
but
if a decision is made to refer a claim
to an investigator
that will only be to help
help collect additional information that
we think is needed that's not to
put pressure on a victim it's not to
um
to make a victim feel as if they're
they're being overly scrutinized it's
it's for information collection because
at the end of the day
a very important piece of this is
collecting sufficient information to
review the claims that come in
we considered and ultimately thought it
was not a good idea but we considered
the option of of proposing that every
claim be referred to an investigator
we ultimately thought that that that was
not necessary and not a good way to go
because we think some claims may very
well be simple enough that no
investigation is needed
we think that
the aeg designee should review a claim
first before
deciding whether to request an
investigation because
again
an investigation may not be needed but
also if the ag designee has first
reviewed a claim
they'll be in a good position to focus
any investigator on on where to go with
with an investigation into a claim
finally the other reason we didn't think
an investigation was needed for every
claim is that
again in most cases claimants council
will be represented or claimants will be
represented by council and we would
expect that
you know as part of earning the fee that
they would get out of this the
claimant's council will be providing
significant assistance to a claimant in
filling out the claim form with all of
the information that may be needed
there are mechanisms built in throughout
the first phase that
that provide for extra time
if the administrator
feels that there needs to be extra time
so you'll notice through the process
there are various deadlines provided you
know submit a claim there's a certain
amount of time to determine whether a
claim is complete
if more information is requested from
the claimant the claimant has certain a
certain amount of time to to provide
that information all of those deadlines
that are in here can be extended by the
administrator for good cause we thought
that was important because
any claim could be different and the
administrator should have some
discretion to allow for more time to
meet these deadlines if necessary
phase two of of the claims process
involves
the ag designee reviewing a claim
so once everything is submitted
any investigations have been completed
the aeg designee reviews a claim and
indicates their position
that could be anywhere from the aeg
designee reviews a claim and indicates
that
the claim should be approved in full
the ag designee may say
okay we think there's sufficient
information here maybe not sufficient
information here so we think only part
of the claim should be approved
or that the claim should be denied
entirely
the process is designed so that that
determination or that that position of
the ag designee can be modified if
additional information comes in
but but the goal is for
the aeg designee to be able to take that
first um
take that first step
in
in making a determination as to whether
a claim should be approved the idea
behind this is that
is that this process is set up in such a
way as directed by the bill that it
starts out as a negotiation
a a negotiation that is that
comes through facilitation of the
collection of information but it starts
out as a negotiation between the aeg
designee
and the claimant
if the ag designee ultimately takes a
position that the claimant does not
agree with
that's when you get to
phase three where
the
um
the claimant will have three options
if the claimant agrees
has agreed with the ag designee's
position then that will be
that will end the process and the
claimant will will get paid out either
all of their claim or part of their
claim uh depending on what the aeg
designee has agreed to
if the claimant does not agree with the
ag designee's position and this is
important
at that point the claimant has the
option to exit the process entirely
and continue to litigate
so that that's an issue that's been
discussed and i think bandied about a
little bit
in the discussion of this process
a claimant is not required to give up
their rights to litigate to enter this
process
a claimant can go all the way through
the submission of the claim form the
review of the aeg designee the
discussion with the aeg designee as to
what the aeg designee thinks about their
claim they can go all the way through
that
and only if they get to the point where
they realize that they're not going to
be able to come to agreement with the
aeg designee
do they have to face the decision of
whether to exit the process and go to
court or
take this process into phase three
which is where the administrator
which would be the scheduling of a
resolution proceeding before the
administrator
so basically at that point a claimant is
able to say
okay
i don't have an agreement here on a
settlement
i can either take my chances and
and um argue my case in front of the
administrator within the caps provided
by the bill
or
i can go back to court i can exit this
process and take my case to court the
advantage obviously of going before the
administrator is that that will that
will be a much shorter process than
going to court but the claimant will
have that option
so a claimant can go pretty far through
this process without ever having waived
their right to litigate i think that's
important because i think i think it's
just important for the committee to
understand that a claimant does not
waive their rights to go to court to
enter this process
so if a claimant does
elect to go forward
uh and and have a resolution proceeding
in front of the uh the the administrator
the claims processes we've laid out here
uh it leaves a fair amount to be
ultimately be set up by the
administrator because we felt that
whoever the administrator is is going to
need to have some discretion in how they
want to set up a resolution proceeding
but the statute does provide that
the maximum length of a hearing would be
three hours
and the statute does provide that
claimant can have their their attorney
present and that the claimant can
request the opportunity to to speak
with the with the administrator
and then there's a decision within 30
days of the hearing
so we've admittedly left this somewhat
open
because we we think it's a good idea for
the administrator to have some
discretion in how they would set up
a resolution proceeding
after a decision by the administrator
or i should say a decision by the
administrator is binding it's not
appealable but there is an opportunity
for parties to request that the
administrator correct any errors so if
there are any mathematical errors made
or any other sort of clear errors
there's an opportunity to request that
the administrator correct those errors
so that is that's a high level overview
of the claims process again it largely
tracks the statute but it it's meant to
fill in some details that the statute
doesn't provide um because as we just as
we were discussing as the legislative
legislative process went along
um it would have been impossible i think
to provide every detail in the bill we
knew that we were going to have to leave
some detail to this process
so the second piece of this as i
mentioned before
are the valuation guidelines
that begins on page 21.
and again this this piece of the package
really governs how to value claims so
the claims process was the procedure how
you submit a claim how it gets reviewed
how the parties negotiate and have an
exchange
how the administrator schedules a
resolution proceeding that was the
claims process
the guidelines govern how to how to
value a claim
so again
the goal of these guidelines is to
ensure that
that claims are valued fairly and that
similar similarly situated claimants
receive a similar amount of compensation
because of that these guidelines as
you'll see are pretty formulaic
um
you know it it bears noting that
that
there is some difficulty with the idea
of a formula
of using a formula to try to put a value
on harm someone might have suffered
because of sexual abuse or physical
abuse
that's that's a difficult concept for us
i think that's a difficult concept for
anyone to wrap their head around
i've said this before and i'll say it
again today i think the reality is there
there is no amount of money
that can compensate truly compensate
someone who has suffered
some of the horrific abuse we we've
heard about there's there's no
amount of money that i think is the
right amount of money
so
with that said
there is an importance i think
in in being fair
and again when we have when we know we
could potentially have hundreds of
claimants coming through this process
even if they don't all come through it
initially
eventually hundreds of claimants coming
through this process the best way to
ensure fairness is is using a formula at
least as the as the base of how we value
claims
so with that in mind the guidelines are
are kind of organized according to the
steps that are taken in the claim
worksheet which we'll talk about when we
get to the claim packet
so there's a few steps
that you go through
in these guidelines to value a claim
the first thing you do in valuing a
claim according to this process is you
determine a base award
so on page 23
you'll see listed there the base awards
for sexual abuse
and physical abuse
a question i think some of you have and
it's it's a it's a natural question is
where did these numbers come from
and there's a couple points on that
first as we talked about during the
legislative process
we in our office have done extensive
research to try to determine
what the average
settlement amounts have been around the
country for claims related to sexual
abuse and physical abuse
for
sexual abuse
we continue to update our research but
but broadly speaking we ultimately
pinpointed an average of between six
hundred thousand and eight hundred
thousand dollars per claimant
uh our original average was closer to
five hundred thousand dollars but as we
had discussions with claimants council
and looked at cases that they suggested
we look at
we ultimately included some of the cases
they suggested we didn't include others
depending on our evaluation of how
similar those cases were but
ultimately our average landed in the six
hundred thousand to eight hundred
thousand dollar range
so one of the ways we
selected these numbers was to take
all of the information we know at this
time about the population
of claimants that is out there
and do some very rough modeling
based on their allegations to determine
what these numbers should be
to land this process in the right
average range so that's one of the
things we did admittedly there's no
certain way to do this we only have
limited information
and there's no way to model this exactly
so that
this is a
there's a there's an estimation exercise
that runs through all of this but that's
one of the
one of the things we did to arrive at
these numbers
the second thing we did um is we
considered the numbers that were used in
negotiations we had had with claimants
counsel before the legislative process
ever began
so as i noted during the legislative
process we had many
we had many exchanges with claimants
counsel regarding a potential way to
develop a settlement mechanism for these
cases and that included
this type of matrix i'll call it a
matrix that you see before you
for the categories of sexual abuse the
numbers are within the range of those
numbers that were being discussed
so i'm limited in what i can tell you on
that because we
we had agreed to confidentiality in
those settlement discussions but i do
think it's important for this committee
to know
that
the per incident numbers that were
discussed
were
were with or i should say these numbers
here are within the range of the per
incident numbers that we had discussed
with claimants council in our
discussions before we ever got to the
legislative process
so those are really the two kind of the
two major
things we considered in arriving at
these numbers
for physical abuse
the the average
award or settlement that we were able to
pinpoint through our research was
roughly sixty thousand dollars
that's what helped us
arrive at a cap of 150 000 during the
legislative process
so again we went through the same
exercise when
when developing these per incident
numbers we tried to use the information
that we do know about the population and
do some very rough modeling
um to arrive at numbers that would land
the claims in within the averages
so i just i wanted to give you a little
bit of an explanation there on how we
arrived at the numbers we arrived at
that that explanation sort of flows
through this entire process so when we
go through
the the aggravating factors and the
multipliers associated that
that all ties back to what i just talked
about trying to kind of
um base it on the rough modeling of
using the information we know
about this population in order to to
land at the averages that that we feel
are are
are appropriate given our research
so back to the process the first step is
to determine a base
award
the second step is to determine what
we're calling a frequency multiplier
so that that is and i will explain that
but the frequency multiplier is intended
to account for
the fact that
some claimants will have experienced
more than one incident of abuse
the second step in valuing a claim is to
apply any aggravating factors
so as we as we know uh based on our
knowledge of the allegations
and as we know
in talking with victim advocates and
others
not all
incidents of sexual or physical abuse
are created equal
there can be aggravating factors that
that create more trauma for instance was
a deadly weapon used was
was uh was there more than one person
involved
there are other factors like that
aggravating factors that
that really
would lead to the conclusion that that a
claim should for a particular incident
of abuse should be valued higher so
applying aggravating factors is the
third step
and then the fourth step
is applying any any mitigating factors
which can reduce the amount of the claim
so you go through the first three steps
to get a number
three based on the allegations and then
you apply mitigating factors
which
which can be um which can reduce the
amount of the claim mitigating factors
may be problems of proof
or or other issues that the
administrator feels
necessitate reducing the amount of a
claim
so again page 23 were the or sort of the
values of the base award
the next few pages are just definitions
of the various categories of abuse so
i'm not going to go through those in
detail those are
in many
in many part provided already in the
in the statute that was passed
there's some additional detail in there
happy to take questions on those but i'm
not going to go through those in detail
here
step two applying a frequency multiplier
starts at the bottom of page 29.
so we've set
we have tried to set this up
as a way of recognizing
that
someone who experiences abuse can
experience different combinations of
abuse and it can happen in different
ways
and so that we sort of need to think
about this
as a mix between
classifying something purely as one type
of abuse and also accounting for the
fact that other types of abuse are
are are experienced
the way we do that to the frequency
multipliers are that you start
by taking the number
of times
that someone might have experienced
the worst category of abuse they
experienced
so if that is for instance five if they
experienced five incidents of the worst
category of abuse that they experienced
you start with the number five
for the next two categories of abuse
that they may have experienced then by
by severity
you take the number of those combined
let's just say that's six
and you divide that by two
and so
you'd end up with five plus three for a
frequency multiplier of eight
and then you look at the frequency
multiplier
which is in table three
at the bottom of page 29
and table four
that frequency multiplier
is used
is applied to
the amount of money that's associated
with the worst category of abuse that
someone suffered
so if they suffered the worst category
of abuse that's listed here say two
hundred thousand dollars
and you have a frequency multiplier of
eight
and we're talking about sexual abuse
you look at the table
and you'll see on the table that for a
frequency multiplier between six and
nine
you would multiply the claim by seven
so that would put you at 1.4 million
dollars just kind of giving a
hypothetical example here
so then you have that 1.4 million dollar
number and you go to
aggregate aggravating factors
for the aggravating factors you
basically you would look through this
table and this provides um
various elements that may
cause an abuse to be be more traumatic
and i don't need to read through each of
them but i think you see the see the
examples
any one of these could add an amount to
to the base claim that you've gotten
through the frequency multiplier
so you would just go through this
exercise and and add the appropriate
amounts for any
any aggravating factor that is present
if you go over 1.5 million dollars
per the statute that that number is
capped at 1.5 million so so you might go
through this exercise and end up at a
number that's above 1.5 million but but
it would be capped at 1.5 million
the last step in the process that's how
you sort of
go through the process of valuing the
claim from from a formula standpoint
the last step in the process which is
laid out
i'm just going to skip through the pages
here
actually
is laid out on page 33 it's step four
so taking into account any mitigating or
exceptional factors
so this
this is where the this is where
um
the
the application of any questions of
proof
or
issues of credibility
potential legal defenses
come in
so you could have a situation where you
have you have a base value let's just
say it's 1.4 million but
there's a lot of proof lacking there are
credibility issues maybe inconsistent
statements
other
other issues with the claim that might
lead the ag designee or the
administrator to say
okay if we just use the formula to value
what's been submitted on the claim form
your number would be this be 1.4 million
but because
of these other issues or inability to
get records or the fact that the records
don't substantiate the claim
we need to apply mitigating factors and
so we think the value should be you know
what what the payout should be is
let's just say half so 700 000.
that
that application of mitigating factors
is designed to be
somewhat discretionary first in the aeg
designees review and then for the
administrator if it goes to the
administrator
because of a recognition of a
recognition that we really need to look
at each of these claims on a
case-by-case basis and for
for cases like this and claims like this
where we're talking about events that
happened a long time ago there could be
a wide variation in the records that are
now available
in the witnesses that
were present at the time and said
something and that are available now
in the
in the memories of a victim
in what the victim may have said to
someone else at the time there's just a
wide variety in in the facts that could
be present so
so there's some discretion there in the
application of mitigating factors but
that is really where
that's where you consider
um the issues of proof and other types
of issues for a claim
again i think this
this is
we recognize that this that is a
difficult exercise you know
everything about what we're trying to do
here is difficult
we recognize that there is no um
there's no one standard by which to
measure
what a victim should be able to show
to substantiate their claims there just
isn't so that this is
i also think i think
this recognizes
a key concept which i've talked about
before but which i think is worth
remembering
that there is a major difference between
a victim who simply
doesn't
remember
with specificity what happened to them
but knows for sure that they were harmed
20 years later
30 years later
more years later it's difficult to
expect any victim to be able to say yes
i was
i suffered six incidents of this type of
abuse two incidents of that type of
abuse and three incidents of that type
of abuse
we expect that
um we expect that that that most victims
are not gonna be able to recall what
happened to them with that specificity
but
we have seen through especially our
criminal investigation that
they will they will have a memory now of
a certain number of incidents
so what i'm saying is that
that just because what a victim is
saying now with regard to the number of
incidents that happen to them it may it
may also ultimately not be accurate as
to what really happened 30 or 40 years
ago
but that is a lot different than than
saying a victim is is lying or not
telling the truth a victim could be
telling us what they absolutely believed
happened to them
as they sit here today
and it may actually not be what happened
to them 30 or 40 years ago
i just go through that because that's
part of what this process is designed to
address when we talk about mitigating
factors
it's it's it's meant to account for the
fact that um
that a victim may remember things a
certain way and believe certain things
happen to them
and that we should we should not
we should not question them in such that
we would accuse them of lying to us
but we have an obligation to
to look at all the information to
determine whether there may be
information that would tell us
that
perhaps what they remember
is not
is not exactly
what happened and that's part of what
the mitigating factors are meant to get
at so
i may not explain that as clearly as i
could but but what i'm just trying to
get at is this concept that
we may feel a victim is telling us the
truth and that they were abused
but
there are
when when events are decades old there
are many many factors that could lead
that account to not be
not be exact enough to know exactly how
many incidents occurred and then things
like that
so
that just all sort of speaks to to the
difficulty of trying to value claims
through a process like this and we have
wrestled with that we have we put a lot
of hours into that we've had a lot of
conversations with our victim advocates
on that front
and we've we've sort of arrived at these
valuation guidelines
um
using a lot of or based on a lot of
thought around those concepts
that's in addition to what i talked
about earlier with regard to how we
tried to pinpoint the average average
claim numbers so a lot has gone into
this it is not it is not an exact
science by any means and there is no
no way to i think to construct a process
like this and be able to say
with 100 certainty that
that um
that everything about it
will get us exactly where we need to be
we're trying to balance again the
obligation of
providing fair compensation and treating
people equally and fairly
while
also meeting our obligation to
to um
to respect
the dignity of every victim or claimant
that comes to us and listen to their
listen to their stories
so that
those are the guidelines
and that's basically how they work
we'll be happy to answer any more
questions about the other detail in
there but i just tried wanted to try to
give an overview
overview of how the got the valuation
guidelines work
the last piece of this package is the
longest one but again as i'll explain
you know there
there's a lot of detail in here that
that a victim may not actually have to
interact with
so this is the claim packet
the claim packet begins on page 40 of
the packet you have before you so the
page number up in the left corner page
40.
the first part of the claim packet is is
just the notice
we think it's a this this is what a
victim again will receive so or a
claimant will receive so when someone
comes to this process
they will not be asked to sift through
the claims process and the guidelines
that we just went through those are
governing documents for the
administrator and for any council
whether it's the ag designee or or
claimants council that are involved
to review and understand those are the
governing documents
this claim packet is what a claimant
would receive
so the first page of a claim packet
as you'll see is just a notice and
trying to acknowledge that even just
going through this packet if you're a
victim of abuse can be difficult
and to provide
to provide right up front resources that
someone may want to access if they're
even thinking about going through this
process
we think that's important because we
think
there could be claimants or victims who
come through this process that that have
not been following everything that's
going on
that had something happened to them many
years ago
and the first time they really see any
acknowledgment of it is in in the notice
that this process is happening so when
they get this claim form
we think it's important that right up
front there be just an acknowledgement
that there could be difficulties and
that there are resources available if
they just want to talk to someone so
that's what we've tried to do with this
notice
we've listed new hampshire 2-1-1
we will list additional resources once
we have the opportunity to to
have conversations with relevant
organizations and get their agreement to
be listed here as as just a resource to
contact if someone even just gets this
packet and that causes them to want to
have a conversation before they start to
to work their way through it
the second part of the packet
is the instructions
this is just meant to
to give basic instructions on how to
fill out the packet and
it also provides right up front as
you'll see at the bottom of page 41 how
to request
assistance
and again this is an important concept
because
you know we we know that we have to
recognize that there may be some
claimants who would come through this
process that don't have a lawyer and
as much as we want to try to make this
process as simple as possible
and
you know as much as this process will be
much simpler than litigating
there's really no way to construct a
process like this that that doesn't
contain some level of detail
isn't somewhat complicated and requires
some level of work to go through
so
we
we want to acknowledge in here that we
we need to provide assistance for
claimants who may not have an attorney
and make clear that that assistance is
available
that theme runs throughout the packet as
you'll see at the top of every page
we try to just reiterate if you need
assistance
this is who you would contact
and obviously we will fill in the
content the exact contact information
once we
we know what that is
so the next part of the packet is just
the instructions
um
just gives basic instructions on on what
to fill out
we also
um again
look to make clear as you'll see
in the second piece of the instructions
on on page 42 make very clear that
we want a claimant to do their best to
provide all of the required information
but that you can submit an incomplete
form and it will be accepted and you
will be contacted with someone who would
assist you on how to get through the
process
so again our goal is to reiterate that
at every stage that this is not intended
to be
a process in which
your claim gets kicked back because you
miss one field or many fields
this is intended to be a process in
which you take your first shot at
getting as much information as there as
you can and that that will begin the
process a process in which you'll be
contacted with assistance to collect
more information
that concept of
of not
not requiring someone to necessarily
fill out everything or even most most of
the form in the first instance
is
what we arrived at after a lot of
thought and a lot of kind of agonizing
over the worry that this process is too
complicated
that's the concept that we arrived at as
the best way to balance the need to
collect the information we would need
and the administrator would need to
evaluate a claim
with the need to make this accessible to
victims of abuse
is that we we have to ask for the
information we need to ultimately try to
collect it but
we don't want to put we don't want to
make the victim themselves do all of
that work with no help we want to
provide sufficient assistance to get any
unrepresented claim in through the
process
the only other way to address that would
have been to just cut down i think on
what we're asking for
and
while that's an option that would make
it more difficult to ensure that we are
we're collecting all the information we
need and then we're really we're we're
treating every victim fairly by trying
to pay
similar claims
similar amounts
so the next piece of the
the claim packet and i'm spending a
little more time on this this part just
because this is what the this is what a
victim or claimant would really interact
with
the next piece is just the instructions
on page 44 for collecting and providing
additional documents
again we tried to put a lot of thought
into what documentation we wanted to ask
for from a claimant
and
we're really just asking for
for the basics here i think in addition
to the form just something that
that
you know verifies their identification
we do provide here though that if
someone doesn't have one of these that
they can contact the administrator
to try to work to find another another
acceptable
form of identification and we're very
aware that that you know there could be
folks who have just don't have forms of
identification identification available
to them
i think our attempt with this is to
reflect that we want to
we would want the administrator to work
with those individuals and not just
cut someone off because they don't have
a driver's license or a passport or a
government issued id
the next thing is the sign notice of
filing of claim and partial stay
that is just what someone would have to
file because the the legislation
provides that if you enter this process
you're not giving up your rights to
litigate
but you are agreeing to pause your
litigation while you go through this
process um we think that just makes
sense from a logistical standpoint in an
administrative standpoint so that we're
not
we don't have people coming through this
at the same time that we're
you know
doing motion practice or conducting
discovery in the litigation process
those two things aren't necessarily
consistent
so there are some additional documents
that
that some claimants may need to submit
but there's also a lot of
a lot of optional documents listed on
page 45. so there there are a lot of
documents that a claimant may be able to
submit that would be very helpful
in helping us review their claim but we
did not
we did not want to require claimants to
submit this type of info because many
claimants may not have have this type of
info so medical records mental health
records
diaries notebooks photographs
those might all be things that a
claimant has that they want to submit
but we also want to recognize that many
claimants may not have that so
our goal is was to make those optional
so that we don't make people feel like
if they don't have those documents they
can't go through this process so they're
not going to be able to
to successfully make a claim
but
this type of information is always
helpful so we did want to list it as
something they could provide
provide
on an optional basis
starting on page 46 we just have the
we start in with the basic form
of information that a claimant would
fill out
um
actually that's starting on page 47
sorry
again we we spent a lot of time trying
to
uh wrestling with how to keep this as
simple as possible while collecting the
information we thought was basic
information that would be needed in a
process like this
so i won't read through every section of
the claim form but i
i would just note that
you know we we try to keep the language
very straightforward as much as we can
we try to really structure these
questions so that where they can be
they're yes or no questions with options
to provide additional information
if if you can but not required to
provide a lot of detail if you don't
have it
again
if some of these or even most of these
fields are left empty that's okay
because
the form can still be submitted
and someone from the administrator's
office would would contact a claimant to
to help them
help them provide at least the basic
minimum information that would be needed
to process a claim
again i just think it's important to
remember as i've said before that we
expect that almost everyone who would
come through this process would have an
attorney
so
so i think an attorney would be more
than capable of assisting a claimant
with filling out
filling out these forms
you know with that i again i'm not going
to go through each question that's asked
happy to take questions um
on any specific piece of information we
ask for but
i will just note that
on page
if you look at page 50.
one of the pieces that will come in this
claim packet is a worksheet that i'm
sure you've all seen and
and i will acknowledge right up front
that that worksheet could could look
very complicated not just to a potential
claimant but to anyone who looks at it
that worksheet is optional it's an
optional way for claimant to go through
and try to calculate their claim value
if they would like
but
the basic claim form we tried to limit
to just the the basic information that
someone might be able to tell us about
any abuse they suffered
so you'll see
on page 50 here in the description of
the abuse you suffered section
we try to limit this to sort of yes or
no questions and and number in in a and
a field where someone can list the
number of times they might have been
abused
to try to make it as
simple as possible for someone to to
articulate that
we know in talking to our victim witness
advocates that that a victim of abuse is
not always able to
to articulate what happened
you don't you don't always get
what you might expect to get in a
situation where you just ask someone
what did you do last weekend it could be
it could just be a lot of stream of
consciousness thoughts
which is understandable when someone has
experienced trauma and especially
understandable when someone has
experienced trauma that
is decades old and they may remember
differently now
so we've tried to boil this down
into very basic information
to start and then again
ask for
ask a claimant to provide as much
information in other fields as they can
so we we asked for pages to be attached
and we if you go to page 51
you know you can see we we we would ask
for
just as much information as someone can
remember or can articulate about what
happened to them but this is not
this isn't required it doesn't all have
to be listed out it's
it's optional
and it's an attempt to recognize that
that every victim will be different
in what they're able to articulate about
about what happened to them
so that theme sort of runs throughout
the forums so i'm not again i'm not
going to go through a question by
question but i did want to note that
piece because
it's those basic questions and the basic
number of times piece that we ask for to
be filled out in the claim form
and the claims worksheet which we'll
talk about is an optional tool we think
that's an important tool because it um
it helps
a victim or their counsel just really go
through the calculation to get a sense
of what they would get under this
process but it is not something that a
victim has to fill out in order to go
through this process
something the administrator will
certainly use to or the ag designee will
use to to arrive at a position or arrive
at a value for the claim
but
it's not something a victim has to work
through
so i think the next important point on
this on this claim form is on page 59.
and this
this re-emphasizes what i was just
talking about this is where
you know after a claimant has gone
through the form
they they come up with their amount
this is where you can see that you know
they have the option of of having gone
through the worksheet and and made a
calculation based on that
or just an option of of making an
estimate
because at the end of the day
what's most important for for
for the process is to collect
information about
what
a victim may have suffered
and it will ultimately be for
while we want a victim
and a claimant to we want them to have
the ability
to go through the calculation themselves
in putting the number in their claim
um
that's not necessary for the process
because if the ag designee and the
administrator has the information they
can go through that calculation and
and
essentially tell a victim what their
claim
what they could be paid out on their
claim based on the process so this
page reflects that a claimant a victim
has the option of going through that
calculation or they can just put an
estimated amount down at the bottom
and that amount will be accepted it will
be reviewed and reviewed against the
calculations but from the claimant and
the victim standpoint that's
that's all the minimum or ask them to do
is put some amount down and whether they
use the
whether they go through the worksheet
and calculate the amount
whether they go through the guidelines
themselves and try to estimate the
amount or whether they just estimate the
amount based on
they know the cap is 1.5 million and
they
they think that that they should
should get something they have an idea
of what what they should be entitled to
they can put that amount in there
because we will have collected necessary
information or we will have the
administrator's staff work with the
victim to collect the necessary
information
we'll be able to work through
uh work through that and get to the
right number
and it will not all be on the claimant
to have to do that
so that that is the the form at a high
level
again starting on and i'm i'm not going
to go through this in detail because it
it's pretty detailed but starting on
page 62
you then have just the claim worksheet
i think it
appears complicated at first blush and
it you know it is somewhat complicated
but
after you've read through this and in
thinking about it i think it actually
does provide a pretty good tool by which
to go through and calculate a claim
amount
i think that will especially be the case
once this is put into uh electronic
format in a web-based format
so we try to make it
you know kind of a
simple sort of in the same layout as a
turbo tax type system right where you're
just you're plugging in
information and numbers and based on the
formulas a claim a claim amount is
determined but
when it's down here on paper
i know it looks like a lot
you'll also notice that there are pages
where
you know it will say if you completed
the prior page you do not need to
complete this page if you
and that's that's on a lot of pages
especially starting at let's say page 65
and running through
page 68.
there will be other parts of here where
there are their fields you really don't
need to complete you can leave blank
um
again when this is put into uh to an
electronic format in a website
i think it will be even more digestible
because you will just be directed past
or directed around the fields that you
don't need to complete you won't be
staring at a bunch of empty fields that
may not be relevant to you
that
make it seem so complicated that you
then just don't even don't even go
through the exercise
so that is the worksheet again
you know we recognize there there's
there's some information there it can
look like a lot but we have worked very
hard
to try to make the language as
digestible as possible
and to try to make this as
straightforward as we think it can be
while balancing the need to
to collect
the information that we need to collect
that is um
you know that is really this that is the
package at a high level i know i spent
some time on it and i could have
i could probably
if i went through everything line by
line like we sometimes do with with
pieces of legislation we could spend a
lot more time but
i thought with that what i would do is
just
pause
and
and i'm sure
sure there will be questions but that
that is the overview i have for you
again we've put a lot of time into this
but we do understand that
the committee may have feedback and
we're looking forward to hearing that to
answering questions
and to working to ultimately get this
process approved either today or down
the line so that we can stand this up
for victims and provide this option
again i think we've always thought of
this as
an alternative option to litigation
but presenting it as an option
if if someone
does not believe this process is
sufficient
if a claimant doesn't believe this
process provides enough compensation
they always have the option of
continuing to litigate their case in
court and we will respect that
and we will
we will
conduct ourselves in the litigation
process with
with respect and dignity with having
respect and dignity for the claimant and
and in a civil manner and
and we will do that and we we are
prepared to do that we're prepared to to
litigate the cases that we need to
litigate
so that that is my presentation for you
i hope that was helpful but we are happy
to answer any and all questions you have
and of course to stay here as long as we
need to stay which is always our
obligation in any meeting of of the
legislature so thank you thank you very
much um
that was uh i thought a good
presentation excellent presentation to
to walk us through
i'd like to
kind of go around the room and
anybody that has
comments questions or whatever
but i'd like to sort of do it in an
orderly fashion if we could
so is there someone that would like to
volunteer to go first
senator daniels
thank you
on page four when you state uh who may
file a claim
it's stated as any living former ydc
resident does that mean that a current
resident could not file a claim
uh
i know so i know that that looks
somewhat confusing but the way we've
defined former ydc resident is someone
who resided at ydc at any time
so
if someone is
residing there now they would still fall
under the under the definition but i
believe in the definition you used the
word resided
as past tense
not residing yep i would read it as
allowing someone to
to file a claim even if they're
currently at ydc we
have not
um
i don't think we are aware of anyone who
is alleging current abuse at ydc that
would want to come through this process
uh
that does not mean there aren't some out
i mean there could be some allegations
of current abuse but that's not
at the time we um
constructed the legislation and at the
time we began this process
we weren't thinking like that was not on
our minds but this is intended to cover
anyone at ydc so
the way i read the the definitions has
resided
i mean they res
i think
i think they would qualify
okay
and uh madam chair do you just want me
to go through yes just please continue
on um
as i look at this
by the definition and such there is no
statute of limitations
on how far back you can go is that
correct that's correct okay and then i
guess my final question
uh
is
is there any
recognition given
to the abuse as and as to whether these
state was knowledgeable and negligent
in that or just an individual
um
case without the state knowledge
so i think where that recognition would
come in is in the mitigating factors and
because the mitigating factors deal with
what defenses the state might have
for a particular
claim any legal defenses the state might
have so
so that that is where that recognition
would be given that that you could have
a claim that you go through the formula
and it's valued at at a certain number
and
the issue is not necessarily that um
we don't bel
there are issues with proof as to
whether the events happened
but there may be
particular facts applicable to that
claim
that show that the state would have
particularly strong legal defenses that
could be part of the mitigating factors
that cause you to reduce the claim
amount so i think the answer is yes that
that could be recognized
the important distinction though is that
the mitigating factors make clear that
defenses that just might be generally
applicable
to claims that come through this process
so for instance
a statute of limitations defense
that just could be generally applicable
to any claim
coming through this process that is
older than three years ago
those types of defenses would not be
we wouldn't would not be considered the
mitigating factors but more fact
specific defenses which you seem to be
describing as to whether
whether the state really was negligent
or whether really would have known about
it those could be applied depending on
the case i think in the mitigating
factors okay thank you madam chair
senator bradley do you want to go next
or
okay turn your mic on please
thank you
so
um a couple of concerns um
i think cueing off of what senator
daniels said i think there has to be
absolute clarification on current
residents so if in
um
you know the possibility of
allegations of current abuse
could you move your mic forward
i'm sorry yeah that's okay
um i'll start again i think following up
on what
uh senator daniels said i think there
has to be clarification on
the current resident being able to come
forward
um
and just to ensure that there are no
allegations of
current abuse that are not covered i
think that's really important
um
so this second one is a question i think
we were looking at page 50
and
um
i thought i heard you say that
the description of the abuse you
suffered
is optional to fill out the form but it
says required
what
am i missing or what did i misunderstand
so what what i meant by that senator is
that the
again
you know if someone left this blank we
wouldn't reject the claim but we would
we would follow up to get this
information but i think the basics that
are required
are
the yes or no questions and what's
what's in the table here in the number
what's not required i think is
all of the detail so that that's
to the extent it wasn't clear i
apologize but that's what i was talking
about by what's not really required we
need we would need kind of some of we
would need the yes or no questions
answered and the basic information about
how many times so i would think that
that hopefully would be clarified
um
so
a couple of more things if i might madam
chair absolutely just continue until you
say you're done
i i really appreciate you know all the
work that's gone into this i was a
co-sponsor of 1677
with
representative umberger
i think
you know
you have
um
really worked hard to try to
bring a process forward to resolve some
of these claims
and balance the needs of the state
versus the needs of victims i mean that
that's your job and i you know i commend
you for it
um
i appreciate
what you said about
the fact that you have not had many
claimants counsel
come and interact with you
um
i think you said they have not engaged
so
um
i i would hope that
if we don't move forward today which i
think we should wait
and
have all of the concerns outlined and
then have you back in and have those
concerns addressed i would hope that the
claimants councils in fact do engage
with you because i think
if this is going to work
there needs to be
a process that
at least some of the claimants councils
feel
is workable
and while they may not have engaged with
you they have engaged with us
and so a couple of things that
um
i think need some further discussion
with clayman's council and
you know one of them
is the
multiplier
that
it
is
potentially difficult to get to the
maximum amount because of the
discounting factor
um i think that
you know
what has been
said to us is that
you know
one
um
whether it's sexual abuse or physical
abuse is devastating but multiple become
exponentially more devastating and so
that sort of flies in the face of a
discounting so i would hope that gets
addressed another issue that has been
brought
um
to us
is
the overall complexity i think you've
tried to
you know outline how something that is
complex
is made easy and hopefully
with more discussions
that
um
can to a certain extent be resolved
i hope that there can be more
notification
in places
you know like prisons and things like
that so that
people are advised of their rights if
abuse happened so i think that's
something that should be taken into
account and another concern that has
been raised are
um
well i think
the way it was described by changes
after the fact of this document
um
as being very technical in nature and
and not substantive in nature
um
i
i i think that there has been a concern
raised that they could become
substantive in nature
and
that
that is something that
you know should be resolved so i think
madam chair those are you know some of
the issues that people have brought to
us or to me at least
and i think you know if the
process allows
you know the
council for the claimants to come and
you know
further discuss this with you i think
from the beginning of the process
you know you have been open to that
um
you know whether it was through the
hearing process on 1677
or
um again today
so hopefully
you know those folks that are
you know listening to us remotely will
you know recognize that you're willing
to do that i i hope that that happens
and
that at least some of the
um claimants counsels will find this a
workable process so thank you madam
chair you're quite welcome
senator d'alessandro uh thank you thank
you madam chair
mr attorney general first of all thank
you for appearing before us uh
i think your articulation was pretty
complete
um excuse me i've got two uh real
concerns and i think let's follow up
with one of the things that senator
bradley said the compass of nature of
this document
uh it's very very difficult uh
to go to go through this and and you
went through it with us
and
the number of things that are required
are not required
i i
they're just magnanimous in in my
opinion
and no one's ever tried this before is
that correct has there ever been
a settlement
of this nature
given this kind of of a
of a methodology to solve it
to our knowledge there's never been a
process like this set up through
legislation i think there have been
similar processes processes agreed to in
the context of of litigation but not set
up through legislation like this
it and how many people have identified
themselves to this point
uh to the best of your knowledge
who were abused in some way shape or
form at the at the ydc and the other
entities
it
it's between five and six hundred
they're they're i see news reports now
of of claimants council saying they have
maybe up to 800 clients
but
there's a fairly significant number of
those clients
whose claims stem from
suffering abuse in the foster care
system
not well at ydc so
what we're directly aware of and i'm
kind of i'm estimating here but i think
it's between five and six hundred it's
and then there are additional
claimants out there who
have been brought into the discussion
but really are making claims based on
what abuse they may have suffered in the
foster care system
to get to follow up on what senator
bradley said your interaction with the
uh the lawyers that are representing
these these clients and i i believe you
said during the iteration that almost
all of these people have have
secured
legal representation now if you if
you're ever trying to handle this
document pro se you're out of your mind
i just don't think you could do you
could do it
that's just my my opinion you can't you
and there are people who will fall into
that category because i because i think
of the time that has
that has gone by so uh so i i think the
interaction with with the
with with their representation is uh
i think it's of maximum importance uh we
want to solve a problem
here and we we want to uh
we want to give justice you know justice
uh
justice delayed is is justice denied
some of these people have waited a long
long period of time
so i think those are those are my points
madam chair and i i think that
coming back with uh
an update is probably the from my
standpoint is the way to go thank you
thank you mr a.j
uh
senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair thank you general
formula for your
thorough explanation i do have a few
questions
so
if there are about five or six hundred
victims
and you think the average award might
be as high as 700 000
that would allow us to to
settle
142 cases
does that mean you're expecting to
litigate
four or
four hundred or so
cases
out of the department yep thank you for
the question i so i think the first
point on that is that the average
the average we're trying to pinpoint
kind of the 700 000 that is the average
that the formula would
would
um result in
that comes before applying mitigating
factors so i mean it could be that the
overall average ends up less depending
on what we see
when people start to come through this
process as to whether
you would apply the mitigating factors
in such a way that and that would make
that average come down we just don't
know that
and that's that's one discussion we had
as we went through the legislative
process you know until we
until folks were to start coming through
the process we're not
we won't know exactly what the average
will be so that would be the first point
the second point is that
i think i would just answer your
question are we are we expecting to
litigate
um
400 cases or more we also don't know
that we don't we just don't know how
many people are going to come through
are going to come through the process
but i will say we're prepared to
litigate and defend every case that we
need to litigate and defend
i've always viewed this process as
an alternative option which the state
should provide
but
not
a process that we're putting forward
because we are afraid to litigate and
defend these cases if we need to
so we're prepared to litigate any cases
we need to can't wait to see your budget
request
maybe i can um if i can follow oh yes
please just continue with all of your
questions until you're done described
your
your process to us as you had this
appropriate
number in mind of six or seven hundred
thousand
um
and so as per claimant and so
essentially
you you backed into those
frequency and multiplier
uh factors
to get to that
average award
i i have a concern that that's not
victim
centered
but it's really more about
the department
what what the department
needed to do
to get to that
number so i hope you'll
take a look at
how those factors
are really are they victim-centered
yeah i would just respond to that by
saying that that was one
factor we looked at in trying to get to
those numbers again it's it was uh
it's not an exact science
so it was we we
we used that
because we're being guided by the we use
the averages because we are trying to be
guided by those to stay within the
numbers set by the legislation but we
also tried to think about what what
aggravating factors were more serious
than others so i wouldn't want to give
the impression that the only thing we
did was this formulaic
calculation it's a rough
sort of a
we we used some modeling we we tried to
use be guided by the averages and we
also
tried to um
evaluate
looking at other cases around the
country like what different aggravating
factors
should be valued at so i would just
i would just note
that i understand that um
that anytime you use a formula again as
i said before it it doesn't feel as
victim-centered and trauma-informed as
it could be
and and that's just because we're again
we're balancing
we're balancing the need to make this
victim-centered and trauma informed
while balancing the need to have
to have some type of standard that makes
sure we pay the claims
pay the claims out fairly and treat
everybody fairly and equally that comes
through
the process
thank you
and in our um sexual assault statute
um
sexual assault
doesn't
make a distinction between genital or
anal rape and oral rape
so
i'm wondering what
the justification is for paying
less
for an oral rape than an anal or genital
rape
that again is based on a couple of
different factors one is
is
what we've been able to glean from
from what settlement payments or what
settlement numbers have been around the
country for various types of abuse
also based on again some of the
discussions we had with clayman's
council prior to the legislative process
and what numbers we were talking about
for for different categories of abuse
but but yes i do recognize that you
don't see that same distinction
in the criminal code
and i
i think the best answer i can give to
that senator is again it
we use a number of factors to try to
make sure that we're
or to try to place values on different
types of abuse that account for the
different levels of trauma and it's not
there is no exact science to it and
and there's no um
i think there's no way to do that
perfectly and again there's no amount of
money
that really adequately compensates
someone for that type of abuse
that type of abuse that they might have
suffered and that any everyone is
impacted differently
too so i i certainly hear
i hear your concern but that's that's
how we did it
is to look at other cases around the
country um
and also
was based on some of the discussions we
had had and that were frankly had even
before i arrived at the department of
justice with claimants counsel before
the legislative process because it's all
rape right and it's rape of children
um i have two more specific questions
one is
that claimant can provide that can
has the option to provide medical and
behavioral
health records
what is the
process going to be for how long
somebody maintains those records and
what is going to be the process for
confirming that they've been destroyed
at some point and i'm especially
concerned about that since there's going
to be a website
access
for this information as well what is the
security and the privacy protection
so i i can't speak to from a technical
standpoint like the data security and
privacy what i can tell you is that
you know the administrator is housed
within the court system and
and the court system will be working
with the department of justice
the state deals with a lot of sensitive
um private information
and i would anticipate that we would we
would utilize all the same protections
we utilize
for the other sensitive and private
records and information that we that we
keep we would utilize all those
protections for these records
as to a retention period i'm forgetting
i i don't think there was a retention
period in this statute right no so that
you're not covered by hipaa
we're not covered by hipaa
well but we're i think we're covered by
a
i'll just say this i think the
department of justice knows how to keep
documents confidential and protect them
and i'm confident that we will do that
i'd love to know more my last question
if i could
um i see that the claimant has to have
their
application notarized
would it within the
prison the state prisons and the county
jails
do do they all have notaries on staff
and what is the access like for inmates
including those who are on the units
you know special units for
bad behavior how how quickly
can an inmate realistically
get
to a notary
i i don't have an answer for you on that
off the top of my head i i think they
have access because i mean in inmates
are entitled to file claims and file
lawsuits and but i i don't know the
exact
process by which they access notaries
and how quickly it can happen but i do
know that residents in our
um
in our prisons and in our county jails
they do have
they do have access to those types of
resources because they
they file lawsuits they file claims in
various processes and so i i'm confident
we could work to make sure that access
is provided
thank you thank you madam chair
thank you uh senator gray uh thank you
um
page nine
uh section four
uh 14 where you give the three options
uh when i first read this
two days ago
you know the third option says to
withdraw the claim from further
processing
but it doesn't go on to say and continue
litigation
nor does the
um
b c d or e talk about that
i understand that probably an attorney
wouldn't have any problem with that but
someone who isn't an attorney says okay
you know
i'm withdrawing
uh you know having something in there
that says then continue litigation or
follow the format that you had in b and
c where you talk about selection option
one and option two
you know option three
you know what is your rights at that
point
seems to me that it would be clarifying
uh
in that section
and i've got one more and if you have a
comment on that i'll wait
so i
i think that that's provided in
in c in 14c where it talks about the
notice
oh so i see your point
well in 14 c you talk about the second
option
you go second option okay yep so
either add third option in there
somewhere
you know again
i'm not worried about the attorneys that
are reading this
and even though
the good senator who's taking leave of
this right now
says you know be fooled to do this per
se
somebody's going to try it
and the more we can help them out the
better off i think we are yep yeah i
understand that point center yeah it is
provided for in the statute but i
yeah we could work to make it clearer in
this document
the other question i had was page 31
where you go into
the aggregate
aggravating factors
whether or not those are you pick the
highest one or
they're cumulative or whatever and
i know that the multipliers was to pick
the highest one
but the aggregating factors i don't
think in your your talk you told me
whether that is cumulative or pick the
highest these are cumulative so you
would for
for each aggravating factor you just add
up
the the value that would be associated
with each one and then it's a total
amount added for aggravated aggravating
factors so they're cumulative thank you
yep
thank you madam chair
um
i too got involved in in the
forest of trees uh trying to calculate
some of this stuff
and that's why i asked the question
what's the low and the high and your
response is right on you're in the
forest
don't look at the trees so
i was looking at the trees much like has
been mentioned this is so complicated
uh that i got lost in the formulas so my
suggestion to that end
is to divide this document which i
assume you might going to be doing at
some point into different sections
you know
separate documents one document is the
process one document is the required
one document is optional worksheets
so it doesn't look like you have to do
the whole darn thing because right now
you're eating an elephant
so my suggestion is to for simple people
like me
is take the worksheets that they could
do and make them a separate document
it's also you're going to have a hell of
a time if you keep it one big document
with revision management
you're going to have uh version
management's going to be a nightmare so
if you have three different documents
you got a little better chance of
keeping track of it
i did have a process question a
procedure question you mentioned the
administrative hearing
can can a claimant
go through the administrative hearing
and still go to court or once they get
to the administrative hearing that's it
yeah if if a claimant elects to go to
the administrative
the proceeding before the administrator
then they would be waiving their rights
to go to court at that point good thank
you
um
i spent 25 years in direct mail direct
mail business and one of the things we
had always was how
how little can people write
if you look on i'm just i just took page
55 i wrote it down as an example
uh
those lines that are on page 55
humans can't write in those lines
they're too close together so if you
want if you have fewer lines but bigger
spacing because they're never going to
be able to make those lines
let me see
line spacing the other thing is
a few years ago i went to the department
of justice and had a we had a
presentation of online
uh filings and i don't remember what it
was for
uh but the biggest problem that they had
was with attorneys
using the online system
and i'm just throwing that out there if
you might we might want to talk to
somebody from justice about you know
what happened back in the days when we
started going online because they had
more problems with attorneys using the
online system than than citizens so i'm
i'm just saying that
if history repeats itself you're going
to have more attorney problems than
people problems
madam chair i think that concludes my
comments thank you
thank you representative emmerich i am
sitting here reading your name
representative lynn
uh thank you madam sure
i have a number of questions may i just
yeah just just continue until you're
done
thank you uh first i want to say i i
really commend both of you i mean i
think i really think that this i agree
with with the comments that have been
made by by many of my colleagues that
this is complicated but i think as you
point out this is really
this is kind of a complicated thing and
i'm not sure that you could
i i think some of the suggestions are uh
are really good ones and i hope you'll
take those into account but i'm not sure
that
in the end you're going to be able to
make this
considerably less complicated than it is
because that's just sort of the nature
of it so but i do i commend both of you
for your work on this it's uh
i think it's i think it's a fine job
um i have a couple of questions the
first question is you mentioned
very early in your remarks that um you
anticipated that some of the criminal
trials may be beginning in early
and so i i guess my my question is just
is there any
danger that
um in connection with those criminal
trials
if there are claimants
who are also
you know the subject of
of the criminal of of the uh allegations
abuse of abuse against them are the
basis for the criminal charges that
there would be
that someone in the criminal division of
your office is going to be moving to
stay
some proceedings like this
until after those criminal cases are
over
i don't well so i'll start by by saying
that you know throughout this entire
uh
process and by process i don't just mean
this claims process i mean the criminal
investigation of the allegations at ydc
and
um
dealing with the
the the civil litigation that's arisen
out of those allegations
there's always been a tension there or
or a potential that
the civil what's happening on the civil
side could impact the criminal side or
vice versa so we've we've always been
dealing with that tension
i don't have a concern that
the criminal justice bureau will move to
stay this proceeding
because we've we've talked about that
internally as to whether we were
generally going to do that in the civil
proceedings and the decision up to this
point has been made not to do that
and that decision would ultimately rest
with me so if that does happen you know
we'll we can anticipate it and deal with
it
but at this point i don't have a concern
that that's going to happen okay
the next thing i want to ask you about
is i and i know
you and i talked a little bit about this
yesterday but um
the uh you had suggested that there
might be a possibility that the
administrator
would
uh contract
with with someone to
be sort of an advocate or an assistant
for people who are are filing claims and
and i guess my only
question there is
if
i think from what you said if if that
were to be done
the cost of doing that
would be born
by the state
um and i i guess what i'm really
wondering is is there
is there the potential for some conflict
uh
between that
and
it simply and you know instead of
instead of instead of having using that
process just saying to people who seem
to be having trouble well
you know here are here are attorneys
you're a group of attorneys that are
willing to do this or are available to
uh to assist you
um
you know why don't you go get an
attorney and i guess what i'm thinking
there is if they do that then the cost
of that attorney would be on would be on
their shoulders and so
um
you know is there some unfairness
between those two
processes
yeah thank you for the questions i
understand that concern um i
i i don't
i don't think there's a big concern
there and and this is why
when when we're thinking about
an advocate that might assist a claimant
what we mean by that is is someone who
works for the administrator who or who
the administrator contracts with that
could provide basic assistance in the
process that has
advocate training so that they know how
to
to interact with and assist victims of
crime but particularly victims of sexual
or physical abuse
the reason we think we'd want the
administrator to have that resource at
least at hand if necessary is that while
we anticipate the administrator will
have
administrative resources to assist with
the completion of applications
victims of crime typically may that or
someone with that type of training just
kind of more administrative training may
not have the training that an advocate
would have in the criminal justice
context
an advocate who knows how to interact
with and assist victims of crime and
it's we don't anticipate that that
advocate would sort of be advocating for
the
the um
the claimant through the process but
just helping talk with the claimant
maybe helping talk with the claimant
about whether they would like to
retain a lawyer claim it may come to
this process not wanting to retain an
attorney
but
part of what a victim advocate does in
in general for a victim of crime
would be to help them think about
anything they're doing related to what
happened to them including bringing a
civil case and an advocate might help
talk them through whether they want to
hire attorney to bring them through the
process
but that advocate could also just help
them
help them navigate the forms themselves
but then once the claim is submitted
it's not that the advocate is
is going through the process with them
and and advocating for them
in the process so
i
i see the concern that the the state
would be paying for that but i think our
thought is that this
we think it's the right thing for the
state to be providing just the basic
resources to make this process accept
accessible
and for some claimants who aren't
represented and who have not been able
to access the help of an advocate
we think that we should have someone
with advocate training
you know on on standby that the
administrator could contract with
so but i don't i don't think there'd be
a conflict there because that would be
to help them get the forms filled out
and get started in the process it's not
the state isn't paying for someone who
is
who is uh
promoting the claimant's position or
trying to promo or arguing to the
administrator in any way that the
claimant should be paid they're just
helping the claim and fill out the forms
okay no thank you i appreciate that uh
the next question i have is on page uh
of in the categories of base awards for
sexual uh sexual uh for claims of sexual
abuse
um
the though
am i correct in understanding
that under
sub uh subletter e
um that
the
violations of privacy
are would not would only be a basis
for
for bringing
subdivision e into play if
it was the violation of privacy
created a reasonable apprehension of
imminent sexual
assault is that correct yes so in other
words if somebody
if somebody
let me
try to give an example if some if if
let's say a guard
somehow put an unauthorized camera
um in you know in a in the room of an
inmate
and was watching
the inmate you know
all the time including presumably some
intimate things that the inmate might be
doing
um
that would not in itself be a base that
might be a violation of privacy it might
be a basis for criminal or some other
civil
action but
without more to suggest that that was
being
that that that gave the person the basis
to believe that they were i mean
for example if the person never knew
about that while it was going on then
presumably that could not have
been the base you know been a basis for
the person to reasonably believe that
they were about to be sexually assaulted
so that even though it might be a
violation of privacy would not be a
would not be something subject to
section e is that am i correct in that
i think the way i would answer that
yeah i i
i was gonna say i i think that's correct
i always just um
reserve based on the fact that there
could be a set of facts right where
there's a gray area there like a weather
person reasonable whether they ever knew
and when they found out and all that but
but yes as a basic matter that that's
correct
okay because i know i just want to be
sure that we're not we haven't
by the inclusion of violations of
privacy we are not sort of
through this process is not expanding
the reach of the statute to cover right
violations of privacy yes yeah and we we
thought long and hard about that and
before we put that in okay all right
next question is on page the same page
i'm not when i when i see the
i've
the the category c and category d
um if you go if you look
about in the uh on the subsequent pages
of the
intimate sexual touching and
uh other touching it it sort of seems
like they're the same the definitions
are kind of the same it still goes back
to
um
touching for the touching of certain you
know intimate areas for the purpose of
sexual gratification so i'm not i'm not
quite clear if there's
what is the distinction between
c and d
in other words maybe you know if this if
this helps a little bit i know that in c
you give the example of masturbation you
put in parenthesis as an example of what
would would violate c
masturbation
and then it um
but that would i mean i think that would
be
under the definitions that you then give
later that that could fit within either
c or d
um and i i guess i'm not that's what
kind of confused me is it
um
i mean is it it may be perhaps it was
the view that and and i i wouldn't
disagree with this perhaps it would be
the view that
masturbation might be a
more serious kind of
offensive touching than other kinds of
offensive touches i i i i don't know if
that's what you had in mind or yeah i
think that that is the general generally
what we had in mind but i think the best
answer probably to give at this moment
is that if we're going to be making
other tweaks maybe we'll just work to
clarify that
okay no no that's fine that's fine
and then the last thing and this is the
one that really is as i talked to you
about this is the one that is
really um
i'm very very concerned about um
and that is the language on
page 33 at the bottom on issues of
credibility
uh that says a claimant statements make
oh i'm sorry that says a claimant
statements
statements made under oath shall be
presumed credible
unless called into question as uh
described below
and that i guess i mean i had you know
one thing that that i
i didn't mention in our discussion
yesterday but it occurred to me since
then is
i think that this language or language
very close to this was originally in
an a version of the statute
and it was removed um i mean i know i
objected and i think there were some
other there may have been at least one
other person who had concerns about it
but it was taken out of the statute
um and i guess
as i said to you yesterday the thing
that really concerns me about this is
this
this effectively it seems to me
places the burden of proof on the state
it says that if
if a claimant comes in
and makes a claim and there's
no
um that you know that there's no
evidence against the claim it has to be
accepted so the default position is
the claim
you know if the the claim has to be
accepted and that seems to me to be
really contrary
to the law in any other area that that
i'm aware of
and it just
that that really concerns me i don't
quite see why you need that
and um
and it's
it's uh
it's very concerning to me
yeah thank you for the question i know
we we
discussed this yesterday um
a couple
points i would make in response to that
you know the first is that
i think it's important to remember you
know this isn't an adjudicatory process
as much as it it's more almost like an
alternative dispute resolution
process so it you know we there's an
initial stage in which a claim is made
and the ag
designee can
can review it and
form a position
based on the
the factors laid out
and then if that there's no agreement
it would go to to the administrator
which which sort of functions as as an
arbitration
um so that's the first i think that's
the first point so it
when it comes to the burden of proof
you know in arbitration there there is
no burden of proof many times i mean
both both parties sort of start out on
on equal footing
but the second point i would make which
i think is more important
is that
the way the language reads
and the the subsequent language
effectively really just says that i
think it's effectively trying to state
what was stated in the statute that
we're trying to treat each victim with
respect and dignity and that
their statements will be presumed to
have credibility
unless there's something to indicate
that
that they aren't credible or that
there's a question around
around the truth of what they're saying
and that can include
lack of proof or problems of proof
so i i think the scope of factors that
could cause
um the credibility of a statement to be
questioned and maybe the value of a
claim can go down
to go down is wide enough that
that
that i don't think you end up with a
problem where where in order to
dispute a claim or reduce the value of a
claim
either the ag designee or the
administrator has to prove a claimant is
not is not credible there just has to be
something
that would cause that credibility to be
caused into question and that something
can include include a lack of proof so
i i guess that's i know we talked about
this yesterday we had a back and forth
on it that
that's the response i would give but i
think that
you know i understand the concern that
it feels like maybe we're shifting the
burden of proof but
but because this is
really meant to be
an alternative dispute resolution
process in which you start out with
a claim and a negotiation and then
potentially
proceeding in front of the administrator
that
is functionally a lot like arbitration
it
i think that mitigates i think that
would mitigate that concern okay i guess
i'm
you know i'm not quite i i i'm not quite
clear why you needed it i know if you
took that if you took that sentence out
and left all the rest in there don't
don't you get don't you get to the same
place
without the because i guess what i'm
really kind of concerned about here is
this
we have a statute that this is based on
the statute doesn't have that kind of
language
this it seems to me is kind of a
substantive
modification of the statute and the
thing that bothers me really is is that
you know the implications of this
for the future i mean is this have we
started down a road
that says
people who make claims don't have their
don't have the burden of proving the
claims and even though i agree with you
this is we want this to be a very
friendly
you know uh uh
claimant uh
oriented process
that's that's that's saying one thing to
say that they you know that the burden
now sort of shifts
to the
that all you have to do is make the
claim
and if there's nothing else that the
default position is you win
boy that's that goes
pretty far represent if i could uh ask
the lba
to go back through all the changes that
we made to this
and let us know if in fact this
particular
sentence was taken out
we can do that yeah i don't know just in
just a moment i don't i don't know if
i'm not saying that i don't want to say
that you know it
that this was not wanted but i mean it
was i understand
about the burden of and i do i remember
that concept was in one of the drafts of
the legislation we'll just we'll ask the
lba to find it
um okay so i mean we can argue this all
afternoon and uh yeah no no that's but
that that's really that was really i
understand your position and i you know
i hope you understand mine i'm just very
troubled by that um
uh
i think other than that um that those
were my question and as i say on on
uh on balance i think the way you know
overall i think this was really a really
excellent job and with this one caveat
of that one area i'm i think it's
i'm very satisfied with thank you
representative
okay thank you you want me to say that i
went through the whole thing and i did
find a proofing error i did actually
file a claim and found it uh reasonably
uh
easy to do in terms of putting in
numbers and doing the calculations and
following through the whole process
um
as far as the beginning i mean the
questions here i think we're valid but i
think most of what they did was was was
quite good and quite honestly i think
it's really they're the experts i don't
consider myself an expert in terms of
what numbers you put in regarding
particular types of incidents and that
sort of thing
representative wallner
thank you
and thank you attorney general for
what i'm sure was an incredible amount
of work putting this all together
um and i agree with a lot of the things
that have already been said um
certainly
um i was disappointed to hear that uh
the claimant's counsel had not engaged
in this um and had not worked with you
around
developing this and i wondered at what
point were they provided
was it only after
it was published
that we waited for them to engage or
were they
provided materials along the way
they
all claimants counsel were provided the
initial drafts that we came up with in
june i forget the exact date but we
tried to
we worked very hard to get some initial
drafts together quickly because we felt
that there was enough here that the best
way to work with this was to get
something down as an initial draft and
send it out
to see what folks thought and then so
they were provided the initial drafts in
in june we continued to follow up and we
did provide
up an up at least one updated draft
before we submitted it to the fiscal
committee so an updated draft to again
solicit feedback uh the one thing i do
want to clarify just on
we've gotten you know very lit really no
engagement from claimants counsel but
i should also say that with the
exception of of nixon peabody and
with
some back and forth we had with the
association of trial lawyers we also
didn't receive a lot of opposition so um
i just i just want to note that so that
when i say lack of engagement i kind of
mean lack of engagement in that just not
for most of them it's not as if they
said we don't like this at all so we're
not working with you we just didn't get
a lot of feedback
i say that only to note that for the
some of the claimants counsel out there
it's just as likely that indicates they
think it's okay as as it indicates they
think it's not okay we just don't know
great thank you thank you for that um
i'm i'm i'm also concerned about the
conflict how complicated this is it's
sort of it feels to me like um
someone
taking a look at this process and
thinking this might be something they
want to do
um will
by necessity really have to have a
lawyer to do it so the chance that
people would be able to really go
through this process without a lawyer is
probably
probably not a good idea
but also probably not something that's
really within the scope of possibility
for most people
i did have just really a couple of
really
technical questions
on page 49
there are a couple of questions this is
um
this is the claim form
the last two questions i wondered how
the answers to these last two questions
play into
all of this how
how is this factored in the answers to
these questions
are we talking about f and g yes on page
49 yes yep
so
for f you know the first
the first thing we're we're looking to
know is just and
and in many cases we might know this
once we have the person's name or some
of the info but
we want to know whether there is a
current
lawsuit against the state
uh because that will factor into whether
if depending on where we go with the
process that there needs to be a
either a temporary stay or ultimately a
release of the or a dismissal of the
current claims if there's a settlement
through this process but
i think what we're getting at with f is
that if someone's already been
compensated
for
through some other proceeding for the
abuse they've suffered
then
then they would not be eligible to come
through come through this process and
then um
similar
i think similar
concept in in g have you already
received any settlements from the state
i mean f and g i think are related but
have you already received any
settlements the other key point with f
is if someone filed a lawsuit and
ultimately it was for that abuse and
ultimately it was dismissed so that
there was some sort of finding that
there wasn't enough there that they they
would not be able to come through
come through this process and we we want
to know we want to know that
so on these two questions if the answers
were yes they might be disqualified from
going through the process
is that right they may be
but it's also possible that
we wouldn't need more detail i mean if
the answer is yes we'd have to get more
detail behind that answer to know
whether they'd be disqualified
great
thank you and i do hope that
the council for the claimants will
that you will be able to reach out to
them and there will be some engagement
with them
thank you
as you know
i
have this propensity to ask questions
i will uh go through my list here
um
my first question is
um will the ag designee
be required to stay in that position
until all the cases are completed
so that we have consistency
as you said we needed
the formula so we could have consistency
so how are we going to guarantee
consistency
out of the ag designee
i think the i i
i understand the question
and appreciate the concern i think the
best answer i can give to that is we
would make best efforts to ensure
consistency
in the person who's occupying that
position
you know for starters we can never
guarantee that someone may not
leave the office
and we also
can't
can't guarantee that that person may not
have something come up or
some other matter they just need to be
involved in on a given day but we would
make i think we would make best efforts
we
we understand the need and the advantage
of of having consistency in that
position i i'm mostly talking about
um
you know
putting them in a new position you know
going
you know right now they're the ag
designee
and you really want them to be something
else
you know i would look
i would frown upon that
i would
think or ask that you give them the
raise or whatever it is
and you know because i i just think that
consistency in this is going to be
as important as how you
do whatever you do yep and that would be
i mean as with any position in the
office that that's always my approach if
someone's going to take a position we we
ask for a commitment to follow that
position through and that would
certainly be the approach here we'd have
that discussion with whoever whoever
might end up taking that position
okay
thank you
um
i guess that i'm i'm not understanding
why
the ag designee
has any role in how
we pay the claimant
i mean we provided several options
isn't it just the
claimants option which one they want
just just to clarify what
what specific role are you referring to
that the aeg designee would have well
you said that the ag designee
will advise the client on
how to receive the money i believe is
what you said
it was
and it it's in the written text and i
don't remember where it is but
i will find that okay and and get back
to you because it was
my understanding that the ag designee
determined what the amount was
it went to the administrator
who then
agreed or disagreed or did whatever
and then
they were paid as in whatever manner
they chose
but anyhow i'll uh i'll go back and
and find that
okay wherever yeah it's it's here
someplace okay
okay
um
i think you answered that on
page 23 which is the uh
[Music]
designated amounts or whatever it was
that those are additives so i i don't
have a problem with that
i know that
the legislation etc
has focused on
employees
but i saw nothing in here
[Music]
that either as a mitigating circumstance
or whatever
if
children to children
abuse occurred
would that be considered
i'm just
only if that
happened at say
at the urging or because of a staff
member right of an employee if if an
employee
did something to encourage that or cause
that to happen if
if a resident just abused another
resident that
and there was no involvement in that by
staff then that would not be covered
okay i just yeah i know we didn't put it
in the legislation i just didn't know
if it would be considered one of the
mitigating factors
and i guess the answer is no if it's
just child to child right okay
thank you
um
do we have any idea
the approximate length of time in
detention
of
people
you know in other words
if i was in detention for six months
you know in order to get to the number
i would have to have been abused quite
frequently like every other day almost
um
but if i was in detention for two years
you know that
what occurred
you know could possibly occur and i
i saw
nothing in here
that
related to
length of time of either
well they call it detention or
incarceration
so we
we don't
have
say an
we don't have a lot of detailed
information on that or we don't we've
not calculated an average say time of
detention
we will
we we could probably put together some
sense
of how long each person has
has been in ydc if we depend on how much
information we have about them
um
but we don't
we have not
put that as a factor in here in any way
it seems like what you're getting at is
have we factored
factored in anything around you know if
you had say two incidents but they were
a year apart i suppose if you have two
instances if they were a day apart
um that that isn't a factor as in the
guidelines as we've developed them but
off the top of my head i do not
i do not know say what the average
amount of time is that someone's been
someone has been in ydc across the
spectrum of all of the claimants yeah i
i got that okay well it was
it was just a concern that you know i
have
um i think someone else mentioned
something about the
non-substantive changes
and i would um
like to recommend that
those come back to fiscal
at least as an information item
okay so that um
[Music]
what may be
non-substantial to you
may be of concern to us so i would just
like that added
and um
you talked
or well people
that are currently
incarcerated i believe uh senator
rosenwald asked about um
notaries
and uh and you answered that
so
um
that was that was part of my concern but
uh
my
my other concern is um
how do they find a lawyer
you know do they walk up and say
you know commissioner hanks i really
need a lawyer
or you know
because i was abused in ydc
or how do they how do they get to the
point
of
filing a claim and that's a i mean i
have no idea if there's even anyone
currently incarcerated but
there may be
but i i
didn't really see a good procedure in
here
for
the exception
of
incarcerated people
so i
you know i don't know
i i can tell you there are significant
number of these individuals who are
currently incarcerated and
they for the most part have
have the same attorney um
i think in those cases you know the
attorneys
they they were connected with their
attorneys through other
other residents so so kind of through
word of mouth
but to your question of for someone who
is not already
um
does not already have an attorney
i
i don't know what that exact process
would be as to how someone might come to
get a lawyer and that's something we
could talk to
talk to the department of corrections
about but i but i do know that
residents often get lawyers so this this
happens i mean and they
i i just i just think we need to say
something in here
that
takes care of that it's not it doesn't
have to be lengthy or anything but
that we are recognizing that we have
incarcerated people
and the last thing last question i have
is
how many public defenders are we going
to have to
use in this process
well we have
we've indicted 11 individuals
so
i think they're
all
i'm not talking about the indictments
i'm talking about
the claimants
why
i i'm not sure why we we would need to
use public defenders
for this process yeah
the guy says there the gal says i don't
have any money
but i want a lawyer oh i see so okay so
and and doesn't know whether they're
going to get a settlement or not so
yep and it would appear to me that if
you go through the public defender
role in this
you wouldn't have to pay attorney fees
so i i think in that instance what
someone would be looking to use is is
new hampshire legal assistance or 603
legal aid or one of those organizations
who may be able to provide
uh free free legal assistance so but
that
i don't have i don't have an estimate on
that i will say for these types of cases
it would be very typical for
an attorney to take it on a contingency
fee basis
and so that does
help a claimant who doesn't have means
access an attorney i think most of the
claimants we've seen
are our claimants who would not be able
to pay for an attorney on an hourly
basis they can
they can retain an attorney because it's
on a contingency fee basis but
well should we say public defenders
aren't allowed
know that that if if you
want a lawyer you have to get one from
on a contingency basis or something
well so the public defenders would only
be used for criminal cases so only
criminal not for civil nope no civil
no but what we do what we have provided
in here is that the administrator should
maintain a list of
of attorneys who might be willing to
consult with a claimant on a free basis
so i don't i don't have to worry about
the public defenders no well not in this
context right i'm just talking about
this because i i get concerned that
that might occur there you know
and you know where we stand on public
defenders so oh yes i'll just uh okay
so that is all
that i have
is there anyone that has anything
else
represent or senator rosenwald can we
follow up with other questions directly
to the attorney general absolutely thank
you
[Music]
um
when i would uh if
i think we
are probably not ready
to vote
on this that i think
you probably recognize that there are a
few things that uh
you need to
change and fix and
i particularly liked uh
uh
representative emerick's idea of
actually making it into three separate
documents
so that
you know
for whatever reason
and i also liked expanding the lines but
that's something that that you can you
can do
so if i read
the
legislation
correctly um
we have
30 days
from submission
to
either
approve or reject
so
we received this on the
1st of august okay
so our 30 days are up
on august 30th
so
i guess that
if
i could get some kind of emotion for
[Music]
us to
to meet
on the 30th
to go over the changes that we have
suggested
that would give you
20 days
to
make the adjustments
and
that would you know give
other people an opportunity to ask some
other questions so
um
could i
have a motion to that effect
madam chair i hate i hate to
be difficult but i'm not going to be in
town oh that's a very good reason to
have it on the 30th
and unfortunately it's something i i
don't think i could when when uh
when are you gonna
so i will be i will be out of town on
the 29th 30th and the 31st oh okay well
then what's the 28th
i think the 28th is a sunday oh good
good day for a meeting okay how about
the
26th yeah whatever that friday is
okay
well the problem is is the 30 days and
if we don't do it within 30 days then we
have to give him a written reason why
we could always withdraw it and resubmit
i think if we did that
then that would this clock would start
again whenever we submit
i i think that's a that's that's an
excellent statement because
the
the time limit between now and the 26th
is de minimis so this gives you more
time and it also gives the board more
time to address queries to you okay to
get answers so
you will send me a letter
can we do that chris at this point
okay
all right
the committee's made no action on the
item the attorney general could withdraw
it at any point
okay
so per i guess maybe a suggestion would
be if you tabled it at your meeting here
and we can get you a letter
later today withdrawing it
that way it gives us a chance to get you
something in writing as opposed to just
me sort of saying it here
that might be
and then we will resubmit a revised
package
that
addresses the feedback we've heard here
today
that that would be my suggestion
move to table
okay
all in favor
so i think guess what we have agreed to
is to take uh to table the item
you will come back with a
resubmittal
and then we have now
until
the
9th of september
if you do it today
if you wait till monday then we have a
few more days yeah well we won't be re
yeah it'll be a bit before we actually
resubmit so i think i think you've got
even more than 30 days from today
okay
yeah okay
so we'll uh
we'll figure that out
mr shea when uh when we get the uh
the thing in
so your intention would be to schedule a
special meeting when it's
appropriate to review the item once
right yeah because i'm i'm getting
concerned that our
deadlines are approaching
and that um
you know we can't
when you say deadlines you mean the
september 9th meeting
no i mean the appointment of the
administrator
that's
you know because cases or claimants can
start filing one
january yeah and notice has to go out
november first
so we'll be under a pretty
tight timeline yeah
okay
well that solved that problem
so we'll uh
we'll meet again and
either we will be on the ballot for
november or we won't but we're still
gonna meet
okay
adjourned thank you
thank you
you